foreign
let me share a few things from from my
experience which I am sure
just to be clear format wise diverged
quite
a bit from what you are describing in
terms of best practices duration of IV
Etc and I chose a clinical setting for a
number of reasons and I think we'll come
back to a few of them one was I wanted
to make it as inconvenient as possible
for me to use ketamine so we're gonna
we'll come back to that the second was I
really
wanted to standardize the experience and
have the versatility that IV provides
which is not the case with hitting the
golf ball with intramuscular injections
so I wanted to be able to which I did
ultimately have the ability to dial up
the rate of administration
in the middle of say a
therapy conversation with a therapist
and then at one point I remember very
very clearly dialed up the rate by about
20 25 percent and suddenly things got
very strange and there seemed to be a
distinct lag between my thoughts my
mouth moving and me hearing any sound
which makes it very hard to talk it's
kind of like having a delayed Reverb on
a microphone or a set of speakers when
you're trying to talk it's extremely
challenging and I remember saying John
that was the name of the technician or
medic who a former medic who was
administering the ketamine I said John
things are getting a little bendy could
you please dial back and he was able to
dial back and then I could resume the
session and I I wanted that type of
ability to experiment
the session itself and this is where I'd
love to hear a bit about the setting the
session itself there was an intake
process and
I was in a room sitting in a comfortable
chair recliner effectively
big screen TV and you got to choose your
effectively let's call it a nature video
with scenes of nature with music
overlaid and I standardized on one
Redwood video
and and I should say that was the first
time I had ever watched a video in a any
type of
clinical or serious setting with with
Drug Administration so I found that in
and of itself quite novel
we can come back to the pros and cons of
that at some point and my experience
post session was
and we were gradually escalating dose I
mean starting well below let's just call
it the minimum effective dose that
you're outlining and then probably
exceeding it by quite a bit by the end
and my experience after the session
became a running joke with my girlfriend
because I would always forget something
at the clinic I would leave my wallet I
would forget my phone I would forget my
backpack I would come home I'd put
something somewhere forget where it was
and it seemed like my short-term memory
was just gone for a period of time and
that leads me to two questions so number
one
how common is that that one experienced
some cognitive deficit or short-term
memory impairment for a period of time
and what does the actual setting look
like in
the
clinical setups that you've supervised
or observed is it in a blank room are
they staring at the ceiling do they have
eye shades on are they listening to
music
Etc
I've seen all of the above
in terms of settings and
we've always used blank rooms
partly because
what we're trying to do is to make
ketamine available to as many people as
possible and have the most efficient
settings so in our Clinic which has led
co-led by uh Dr Robert ostroff and
Gerard Santa Cora both experts in this
work it would look like a surgical
recovery route with a number of bays and
everybody has their own space they're
shielded from seeing other people by
curtains and things like that so they do
have some privacy
but the doctors are moving and the
nursing staff are moving from Patient to
Patient to Patient in the session so it
it's more of a strange in some way
almost a communal
experience not that people are wanting
the communal experience per se but but
it is a very efficient way to deliver
the treatment one of the things about
ketamine is that it distorts perception
in exactly the way that you describe so
some groups try to keep the level of
stimulation limited because the more
intense the sensory input on ketamine
the more you get distortions of the
experience
and
it is said by mentors of mine who worked
the emergency rooms when when you would
get PCP and and LSD intoxicated people
come to the emergency room that the
management strategy was the opposite for
those two medications because PCP like
ketamine causes distortions of the input
so the more input that you get the more
distorted Things become but with LSD
there's almost like a battle for control
of your
perceptual world so when you put the
blinders on and produce sensory
deprivation you tend to augment the
intensity of LSD you're withdrawing the
organizing
effects of the sensory world and and so
you tend to have a little bit more
stimulation in the emergency room
setting with with the psychedelics than
you do with with PCP
is there let's see here well actually I
think you answered the question I was
going to ask you if if cost and scale
were in no consideration I suppose I
didn't frame it this way
for the purposes of scaling it makes
perfect sense that you would want
the least cost
the least on some level least space
required at least training right you
don't want it to require a four-string
quartet or something
but if cost and scale were no
consideration do you have any thoughts
on how you might
design the setting would it be any
different I understand the point that
you made which I think probably applies
whether cost is a constraint or not
about minimizing inputs but do you have
any other thoughts on what that might
look like it's an interesting question
my general feeling about ketamine like
most clinical experiences is that when
the patient is comfortable and feels
well cared for and supported that
outcomes tend to be better so the whole
setting that you describe a really comfy
chair a really relaxing video
that's not too stimulating
privacy and quiet
is pretty close to an optimized setting
in the video mainly because
not much happens describing a treatment
where not much is happening during the
infusion if you're going to reactivate
trauma memories or if you're going to
reactivate alcohol memories that itself
is going to be a pretty engrossing
intervention and and probably will
occupy a lot of the kind of
sensory space of the infusion it sounds
like you had some version of that
well there the problem with video well
one of the many potential complications
with video is that not all content may
provoke the warm and cozy feeling that
you may be seeking so I remember
watching for the first time this video
and it's like beautiful redwoods and
rivers kind of creepy not creepy but
like minor tone melancholic music which
I didn't love I didn't expect that or
see that coming but I was already kind
of strapped to the seat and on the ride
so I couldn't couldn't get off in the
middle of
Pirates of the Caribbean Disney World
ride so I was I was in it but I remember
at one point on a higher dose there's
this one scene that popped up out of
nowhere and it was just this it was this
fox this little fox it looked like maybe
it was Patagonia or something like that
it was just sitting on this freezing
cold Beach it was sitting on this sand
and it just looked miserable it wasn't
doing anything I was like why is this
fox here it looked really unhappy
that was not conducive to an optimal
clinical experience